oha 6h is the name of the chamber games i
don't know
what you can always play i had
just actually i don't know if i was
doing well but i'll try again
here this
this pseudo for there is
change again yes it's amazing how
many play it although it's real
nothing at all brings
four I think it's even bad
but well I don't know exactly why
I suspect because of runners how much
more bad it may be exaggerated but it
can be at least it doesn't bring anything
but
I really don't know anymore I
had that sometime ago primeval times
looked at it a bit but of
course also forgotten again
yes yes for the 2064 not yes it is of course strange because
the shape is
so good anyway okay that is of course a
really strange processing that knows there
chooses because here I can
only really only stand
ok king stands well 47
and I have also jumped well and I
can't jump well for a long time here too
some jumpers f2
yes we do that  now maybe six is ​​running
if the player attacking
you grab it doesn't bring anything cd time
to
exceed so well short can he now under
certain circumstances
maybe do the 8
that falls away and
on local I've now considered
maybe jumper the two if one
the idea is
yes i
would like to make guevara justin harry
wörz more unusual with 20 points more
or think they are actually always
the kings of the world
that of course continues to play
i will now how great it
would be or something but
there is no reason to be brave  doing
that depends a bit on the
pawn, hard 23
is probably he can because of that
he always has to cover the weird pawn
there can't really do much so
maybe gain a bit of space
first of
all so
can't move anywhere really
good
king yet  run further forward
maybe
what he does
maybe i have the idea c5 b4 because
the sound of h3 er  had
already somehow apparently somehow
respect before
back
to repeat once again
to show who is asking here in the competition
whether I can do that at all
but well so now it's
probably asleep again my
god
now the question king c5 steadily on around
the seven somehow  consider
probably without the train you
won't get any further
c5 is also stupid
try it i mean it was risky with
less time
but i
don't feel like giving it to her
he doesn't have that
many too many if the sound stays passive now
i'll make king  cvp 3 or
king c4 c5 i mean he has to get
in somehow
then i go here an atom of the seven
king c4 tower c7 king b3
stays passive
thats bad for sure bad like
e.g. 4k once next to playing the four
was before  in here
anyway you have to see how to
get on here the simple
b 4 probably not
i could w  pus your ranks
run recognize not much too
the fathers play
no idea yes I'll go on here to see
how now I intend to continue playing here
you'll get further but I don't
have to admit so now maybe b4
take everything and go to tower
b3 and to  I'm sure they
'll probably be
cheaper somehow, but if
I'm glad I came
up with it at all, given the
little time,
yes, probably, it has won now,
for black people,
probably, I
should actually have to
go through it, or get
both, or both at the same time,
check,
yes
, that's not enough  i break down
or right through
unfortunately if i can't believe that
five the
initiative
was totally totally insane the
mood is just emi
he can just now can just king
the six me now
totally eni i can
do it incomprehensibly well i
actually had to win  since then domains
player was of course nothing me  hr on
the bells, well, but before that it was very
interesting because it was played way too passively
. You
had to place the order earlier, so
somehow Rhein began to be allowed to do so, so he can't
allow it, it's too passive